[Music]
in our series on the new normal the
world from home we want to bring the
world to you since travel as you know is
very limited this summer this morning
how some people are still getting closer
to nature through technology South
Africa is one of the world's most
popular tourist destinations with nearly
17 million foreign visitors in 2019 it's
a great place many of the tourists who
traveled to Africa go on Safari
but as Debora patta shows us with almost
no international travel travel rather
because of the coronavirus there is a
new way to see the animals up close and
personal you don't need to get on a
plane to see this it can all be viewed
from the comfort of your own home raw
unedited wild and stream twice a day
from the heart of the South African bush
the Garcia family from Miami was
supposed to visit a South African
wildlife Park in April instead they've
had a front-row seat complete with
Safari gear watching everything from
baby cheetahs suckling their mother to a
joyful herd of elephants cooling down at
a waterhole welcome onboard everyone my
name is Lauren and I do have BK on
camera
viewers bump along dusty roads with game
Rangers like Lauren Arthur as she tracks
down incredible animal sightings filmed
from a mounted camera on the back of the
safari truck I think people have been
able to tap into that during lockdown
and realize how important nature
actually is while the world has come to
a standstill Nature has not a circle of
life has sure been busy from the birth
of these hyena Cubs to baby leopard
learning to walk the walk or lion cubs
roughing it with their mum we've got to
remember that in this moment of
confusion and not knowing what's
happening in the world that nature has
been through this before and and we will
get through this gram Wallington is the
co-founder of wild earth which has been
streaming virtual safaris for 13 years
hello
but since the world started shutting
down their global audience has been 5
times higher from the US with around 2
million viewers a month a third of which
are Americans during the game drive
Rangers field questions sent in live
from the viewers at home Jensen you are
8 years old from Illinois hi there
Jensen and you're asking to move
giraffes ever hang around together
turns off they do if they aren't
competing for the attention of a female
but generally they're fairly aloof
social distancing it seems comes
naturally to them prior to the global
pandemic wild earth was streaming at
safaris to cancer wards in several US
children's hospitals like this one in
Washington DC like tourism around the
world South Africa's nearly 30 billion
dollar travel industry is really private
game lodge owner euphony Kirk hosts
virtual safaris he's concerned that
conservation which is funded by tourism
will suffer
you need tourists to bring the money so
we can buy our anti poaching units and
we can pay the stuff and we can get the
money into the economy that lives off
nature
order for them to protect the nature hi
Gary in California but Wallington
billion that virtual tourism could
redefine travel in a post covered
nineteen world if everybody who wanted
to come to Africa on Safari came there'd
be too many people and we'd actually
damage the thing that we all enjoy so
much so I think that in the future
virtual tourism is a way for everybody
to enjoy without destroying it with so
much uncertainty surrounding global
travel experts believe the virtual
safaris are not only filling a void that
are here to stay for CBS this morning
Debora patta sabi sands South Africa